besondere zeiten besondere auto muss man
sagen und besondere sendung und settings
wir befinden uns hier am viren sicher
verbunkert studio des phoenix centers
mitten in berlin er war keiner weiß wo
und fan der sendung ein bisschen anders
als sonst wir sitzen und im übrigen weil
wir keine witze über die ganze
geschichte machen namens corona weshalb
wir uns auch gespart haben irgendeine
provokante steile these in den titel
reingeschrieben kollege aufsteigen im
home office mit brille und tiefer
gelassenheit wie ich sehe dass sie ja
nur sieben rollen klopapier gekauft
haben ich könnte ihnen auch noch an
abgeben denn sie wollen ich habe jetzt
umgesattelt haben sie noch zu sprechen
das ist sie wollen ich bin klopapier
china geworden weil das scheint mir doch
der bessere aber dann merken sie schon
dass ein gefährlicher weg auf den ich
mich beginne dann da fängt man schon an
sarkastische witze zu machen mit einem
thema über das moment die leute nicht
nur keine witze machen sondern ehrlich
gesagt auf eine art und weise
gleichgerichtet möchte ich sagen denkt
man halt total nicht ganz sie wollen
sich schaltet sagen stimmt gleich
gefallen hat er sagte hallo
nein quatsch sondern freiwillig
sozusagen ergeben sich die leute diesem
thema hin mit einem so als wäre jeder
ist ein kleiner virologe jeder ist ein
epidemiologe jeder weiß ganz genau was
man jetzt richtig machen muss jeder
glaubt alles was diese ganzen virologen
ept modul sagen obwohl er sich am
nächsten tag wieder widersprechen wo ich
sage keine vorwurf weil sich auf neue
krankheit wissen es auch noch nicht so
richtig aber die art und weise wie wir
sozusagen an den lippen von deren kosten
hängen an den lippen von herrn piccoli
wie wir sozusagen immer folgen was das
robert-koch-institut gerade jetzt wieder
sagt das erschreckt mich ehrlich gesagt
wir sind 100 prozent von diesen leuten
abhängig die selber mache es gerne auch
schon ganz gespannt was was erschreckt
sie erschreckt sie der umstand dass wir
von denen abhängig sind in einer
situation wo es eine so spezielle
geschichte ist so speziell wenn man so
will bedrohungen anführungsstrichen ist
das halt nur noch ganz wenige leute sie
ausgehen oder macht ihnen angst und das
ist es doch in wahrheit dass die meisten
der leute jetzt plötzlich dem start
folgen und der regierung folgen und das
tun was ihnen allerlei zumindest
angeraten wird oder gar
verlegt wird also dass man endlich auch
eine lange zeit ich bin ja der linke sie
sind ja der liberale ich bin ja der gene
ich habe da gar nichts gegen den staat
deshalb müssen wir hier auch mal als
leitfrage ist unsere kleine sendung hat
der staat das eigentlich gut im griff
machen die das eigentlich gut und ich
bin da ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
skeptisch weil wenn sie natürlich für
die sie wenn sie in hama sind es alles
für sie einen nagel wenn sie in
epidemiologe sind dann ist sozusagen ihr
hauptziel die krankheit keinen umständen
auf jeden fall in der ausbreitung zu
behindern egal was es kostet und ich
würde sagen als journalist
entschuldigung aber auch als bürger aber
vor allen dingen als journalist ist es
eben mein job ja jedoch der seinen job
ist ja auch ihr vielleicht ganz gut so
in so einer demokratie mein job ist es
aber fragen zu stellen
zweifel anzumelden jetzt werfen sie sich
in sonne in seine helden pose als würde
irgendwann irgendjemandem verbieten eine
frage zu stellen dass das das ist den
eindruck ich tut mir leid jetzt kommen
sie echte nicht anders war heiser nein
ich mache jetzt hier nicht auf little
afd und so ich sage nur der weg der da
jetzt beschritten wird und zwar mit
einem echt sehr sehr sehr großem tempo
und sehr massiv ich möchte gerne zb
ansprache der bundeskanzlerin kam gar
nichts darüber was ehrlich gesagt wurde
freunde wie lange wollt ihr das
eigentlich auch weil das durch habe das
ist auch der punkt das finde ich das
fand ich gerade das sympathisch sind
also ist das das richtige zeit um mich
zu sagen kluge daran dass sie nicht
versucht hat dinge zu prognostizieren
die offenkundig keiner prognostizieren
kann sondern schritt für schritt jetzt
versucht einen pfad zu folgen der von
der über ganz überwiegenden mehrheit der
wissenschaft nahegelegt wird namens
reduziert eure sozialkontakte dass er
reduziert die infektion und dann kommt
das ding vielleicht zum stillstand
mindestens aber davon hoffen das
gesundheitssystem in der behandlung in
der weiteren der fälle nicht voll zu
überlassen oder gar zu sprengen das
finde ich einfach so pragmatischen und
da bin ich fertig oder ich bin auch der
paragraph von uns beiden
aber natürlich außerordentlich dabei ist
so pragmatisch zu sehen und eben nicht
in einem schritt von vergleichsweise
wenig auf vollalarm zuschalten und
zusagen ausgangssperre
wir fahren jetzt panzer durch die
straßen damit uns sorgen und lösen jede
versammlung auf dem spielplatz auf und
so zeugs
was andere länder gemacht haben ja aber
würde wenn sie diesen leuten die die
sozusagen im moment unsere unsere unsere
intellektuellen führungsfiguren sind
herr droste ja herr kekulé die kollegen
vom robert-koch-institut oder auch diese
jüngste studie aus england vom imperial
college die jetzt herumgereicht wurde
wenn sie sich das angucken ich meine man
kann das ja alles recherchieren ist ja
auch teil ihres und meines davon kann
sich ja da auch ein lesen diese dinge
dann merkt man diese kollegen rechnen
mit zurzeit horizonten irgendwas du
zwischen sechs monaten und zwei jahren
und da kann ich das sagen okay das ist
alles super interessant aber das sollte
die bundeskanzlerin vielleicht auch
sagen denn wenn sie das was wir jetzt
machen sechs monate durchziehen oder 18
monate durchziehen dann ist nicht mehr
sehr viel übrig da vorne dabei
ich bin ja ich bin rückfällig dabei
einmal sagen worum es geht versteht sie
könnten jetzt ja auch kommen und mir die
die bilder aus bergamo vorhalten von dem
militär lastern die serie abholen so zu
sagen man kann sich jetzt ja auch
polemisch sozusagen sachen im großen und
ganzen ist dass du dich ja nicht machen
ich bin ja auch nicht gegen autobahn
fahren nur weil auf der autobahn
menschen sterben was ja auch der fall
können sie das noch mal sagen na ja wenn
man so sehe ich glaube auch hier haben
sie recht sehe ich genauso
es gibt einen punkt an dem spätestens
man anfangen muss abzuwägen ob man dabei
ist das haus in die luft zu sprengen nur
weil man den dachstuhlbrand löschen
möchte es gibt einen punkt wo man
abwägen muss legen wir die komplette
wirtschaftler machen wir millionen leute
arbeitslos jagen den euro in die luft
weil italien seine schulden nicht mehr
bezahlen kann erzählt er
momentan wird die lebensmittel aber den
punkt glaube ich haben wir lange nicht
erreicht weshalb ich es für richtig
finde sich schritt um schritt auf dem
noch einmal von der mehrheitsmeinung der
wissenschaft vorgeschlagenen fahrt in
diese richtung zu bewegen um zu gucken
ob nicht das gelingt was in china
singapur und südkorea geglückt ist
nämlich innerhalb von 6 4 6 noch nicht
mal acht wochen die neue infektion zu
stoppen
das heißt sie haben moment die haben
gemacht was jetzt hier in deutschland
angefangen wird zu machen bzw
relativ weit fortgeschritten ist in
manchen bundesländern und dann hat sich
keiner mehr neu infiziert also von den
50 millionen ungefähr die china
abgegrenzt hat wie
insel in der betroffenen region rund um
die betroffenen millionenstadt haben
sich am ende wenn man den zahlen trauen
darf mit allem vorbehalt das ist eine
diktatur muss man die falsche nummer
ganz andere sachen aber wenn die zahlen
stimmen ungefährdet haben die die zahl
der infektionen auf 80.000 begrenzen
können audorf 50 millionen vorsichtig
ich glaube dass ihr könnt natürlich
jetzt nicht das ist übrigens auch
insofern finde ich es ganz gut dass wir
dieses gespräch jetzt hier exemplarisch
führen vielleicht auch für alle anderen
leute die sich zu hause und wir kommen
dadurch jetzt unseren grenzbereich weder
sie noch ich sind epidemiologen und
virologen wir verstehen davon innerhalb
des ehrlich gesagt gar nichts und was da
genau passiert ist verstehen wir in
wahrheit auch nicht so genau weil das
ein komplett in transparentes system ist
was sie jetzt machen ist unter umständen
ich sag nur unter umständen ich weiß es
nicht genau ist unter umständen ein
falscher vergleich weil erstens sind bei
uns in europa die wirtschaft über diesen
punkt hinaus sind wo das vielleicht gar
nicht mehr funktioniert und wir außerdem
auch gar nicht in der lage sind auf
diese weise stücke sozusagen
herauszuschneiden und so zu isolieren
wie die das gemacht haben 50 millionen
sind im milliarden land china
wahrscheinlich auch ein bereich wo man
sozusagen abgrenzen ich will ja nicht
wer das ist
ich will gar nicht über china rechten
wir werden das bedeutet mehr lenken
wollte war es gibt drei länder in der
welt denen ist etwas geglückt
aber sie hat mich die zahl der
opposition zu begrenzen ohne auf eine
ewig lange zeit strecke zu müssen die
ihnen die wirtschaft komplett ruiniert
hat die chinesische seite läuft wieder
an aber der der zeitpunkt ist bei uns
bereits verstrichen und was mich so was
mich so irritiert ist alle beten jetzt
sozusagen diese grafik an flächen
verkauft die auch sehr einleuchtend ist
ja unbehandelt ist die kurve so hoch
dass sie die kapazitäten des
gesundheitssystems weit weit übersteigt
wenn man sozusagen diese maßnahmen macht
hält man die kurve unterhalb der
kapazität des gesundheitssystems das
leuchtet mir auch total an das versteht
jeder dass die auch ich und ich bin mir
macht es immer schon schlecht gewesen
aber ich sehe dann eben auch dass der
zeitstrahl nach rechts natürlich immer
länger und immer länger wird
und dann frage ich und darauf gibt es
einfach keine antwort das beantwortet
einem niemand freunde wie flat wollt ihr
denn die curve machen dass der zeitplan
nach rechts und angeht
das hier einfach kein haus saniert dann
hätte man hätte meinen können hätte man
formulieren müssen wie flat wollen sie
die kirche machen damit es nicht zu lang
wird auf derzeit ex so wollten sie reden
oder sie haben so ein bisschen jetzt
schon diesen virologen schlag drauf also
sie sind noch keine ahnung wie ich sie
haben sich schon angesteckt mit der
virologie und lustig gemacht weil sie
weil sie noch einmal sie verfallen in
einen technischen nein das ist in so
einen wissenschaftlichen maximal ismus
oder technischen maximal ismus von wegen
das ist nur richtig dass kann nur
richtig sein und man darf den weg nur
gehen wenn man ihn bis zu ende schon
kennt und genau sagen kann was sie beim
ersten schritt abschätzen kann was die
gesamtkosten des kompletten weges sein
werden das ist aber hier nicht der fall
das verstehe er sich und das ist ja ein
ausstieg also die bundeskanzlerin hat
gestern einen satz gesagt die lage ist
ernst und sie ist offen
und das ist vielleicht ein begriff den
man besser versteht wenn man sich markus
biografie und ihrem weg aus der ddr in
das wiedervereinigte deutschland ein
bisschen auskennt aber gehe ins offene
das heißt g also das ist offen heißt es
kann gut oder es kann schlecht wenn das
weiß aber keiner
aber trotzdem muss man anfangen sich das
bewegen ich gerne gehört hätte ist ich
hätte gerne den satz gehört
ich hatte genau das gerne gehört wir
werden das haus nicht in die luft
sprengen nur um den dachstuhl zu retten
diesen satz hätte ich gerne gehört aber
das sagt ihnen keiner und auch
fairerweise des alters ist geläutert ich
verraten
das ist falsch nennt maß und mitte wenn
herr söder ich rede doch gerade wenn sie
im moment ist es so wenn sie fragen wie
lange müssen wir diesen maßnahmen
durchhalten antworten so lange es nötig
ist und das ist eine art von
totalitarismus der macht mir echt angst
aber wenn man sagt so nötig ist
wahrscheinlich muss ich jetzt gleich den
saft abdrehen oder eine gesichtsmaske
vor die kamera halten das stimmt einfach
nicht dass es faktisch falsch und jetzt
ist auch ein bisschen aufpassen was für
den politikern unterschieben und um es
dann zu kritisieren sowohl die
bundeskanzlerin sprach glaube ich von
augenmaß und maß und mitte herr
mindestens herr söder sprach gestern
davon
herr laschet immerhin der chef von 17
millionen menschen in nrw als
ministerpräsident sagte ausdrücklich
wir müssen darauf achten die solche die
pandemie so gut wie möglich zu bekämpfen
aber wir dürfen dabei nicht die
wirtschaft ruiniert
denn es muss dann nachher nochmal weiter
gehen also dieser zweiklang achtung es
könnte ein punkt erreicht werden an dem
müssen wir uns überlegen welche mittel
sind noch wie soll man sagen angemessen
wenn wir nicht die komplette regierung
komplette weltwirtschaft beziehungsweise
zunächst einmal deutsche wirtschaft
flach legen wollen dieser gedanke steckt
schon in den köpfen drin und daher
wissen sie ja auch nicht und können auch
nicht sagen wo dieser punkt erreicht ist
sie wissen nicht wie schnell die beiden
wegen eine so arbeitsteilige wirtschaft
wird die deutsche darauf reagiert dass
der dienstleistungssektor jetzt wirklich
unter wasser gedrückt wird
die ganze kulturbetriebe und so weiter
jetzt mal nur als wirtschaftlicher
faktor betrachtet wie schnell das
ausstrahlt den rest der wirtschaft und
die dann mit lähmt das weiß man auch
nicht genau so eine krise in dieser form
ausgelöst hat hat auch noch nicht
gegeben
sie wissen ja wer nachher so steil
runter geht danach wieder bomben wieder
rauf oder ob es danach zu krieg diese
krise hätte aber auch vor zehn jahren
einen komplett anderen verlauf genommen
weil sich das internet und durch diese
starke emotionale mobilisierung der
leute sie an vollkommen anderen trug
reinkriegen als sie sozusagen aus
taktischen gründen wahrscheinlich sonst
rein bekommen hätten und das finde ich
macht mir echt angst das war das also
übertragenden sinne durch das wird der
virus durchs internet zu übertragen und
durch e mail und whatsapp aber ich gebe
zu und kollegen die aus stand das war
heute eine ganz schöne sendung ist haben
sie gar nicht schlecht gemacht sie haben
zugehört sie waren
sie waren aufmerksam und darum habe ich
ihn mitgebracht ein bisschen was nicht
nicht geheim sondern nur vom munde ab
deuce
um nicht zu sagen ganz viele nudeln für
sie aber sie müssen sie sich wie abholen
sie haben mir nudeln mitgebracht ja aber
die tomatensoße müssen sie selber machen